We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two. David P, uh, I'm going to
play this voicemail for you with a total neutrality
in the sense that I am not going to prejudge
for you whether this is a serious voicemail
or it is someone who's trolling me. I have
an opinion. Okay, let's take a listen to it
together.
Hi there. David, you must, I don't understand
why you think Trump is a KKK member. The Democrats
started the KKK. Hillary Clinton Love Robert
Bird. Look him up. He was a grand wizard of
the KKK. Where is your history? I don't think
you do any kind of like studying. How did
you do in school? And you don't even know
your history. Trump is take it down. Pedos
big time. What do you think the Q movement
is all about? Pedophilia. Who Do you think
is running this government and the world?
A bunch of Patos look up George Nader who
was just finally busted for screwing up a
11 year old boy or something, a 14 year old.
It was with him from Europe. He screws little
baby. They have the on his phone that they
caught him with. Trump was behind that also
Epstein. Who Do you think is taken down? Epstein
truck. He hates Epstein.
Yeah. So listen, it goes on for like two more
minutes. Do you think that is real genuine
or do you think it is not, I'll now give you
my opinion. I believe that that is completely
genuine. Um, that, uh, in looking at the caller
ID and the call history of that individual,
they have slowly become wackier and wackier.
Um, and I believe that that is not a parody.
I know that for some of you it's hard to believe
that that's a real person that exists in the
world. That is my best assessment based on
everything. I know. If you are shocked by
that, then maybe you're not paying attention
because that is what we are up against right
now. Pedos Q Q and on conspiracies. Uh, I,
you know, why did you say Trump is in the
KKK? I never did. I mean it is, this is someone
whose brain has, has rotted out.
This is the equivalent of if you just have
candy, Candy, candy everyday in sugar, sodas
and you never brush your teeth and then four
years later you wake up and you know what,
what's going on with your teeth. The equivalent
has happened from putting the, the, um, whatever
is analogous informationally to sugar sodas
and sugar candy, uh, in your brain is what
has happened to this color. And I believe
it is 100% real. Send me your thoughts if
you disagree. Great bonus row for you today.
Become a member. Become a patron. I'll speak
the